a design studio for the digital age
design research Aguirre your stunt her
PhD students are creating clothes which
in a few years are expected to be
everyday garments like a cardigan for
stroke patients and climb so here we
have a tiny micro controller which is
like a mini computer it's attached by
velcro so it can be removed for washing
if I have an emergency I just have to
make a certain gesture in this case
touch my chest and then a phone call is
made via bluetooth on my smartphone
which I have in the pocket down here
smart for was a unit on other clothing
gadgets are designed to gather
information than torn forms of ID review
the answers can be built into my
sneakers for example right and then I
have an app that allows me to track how
fast I've run and compare my performance
with friends I think these things will
soon be common in our everyday sweaters
and jackets in TV advert your subject is
the growing interaction between humans
and machines today the one is almost
inconceivable without the other
what kind of music you can no longer say
that's the digital world and that's the
analog or real world everything is
linked together so that we have one
blended entirety a Ganza skipped
digitalization offer society many
advantages the flow of traffic can be
optimized energy networks made more
efficient and this huge potential for
savings but there's also one major
disadvantage a loss of privacy
you're not Elizabeth the disadvantage is
that many people particularly the
Americans say privacy was yesterday I
have to give that up now that would of
course be a huge infringement of our
civil rights I'm not prepared to give up
my privacy the question of course is
where are we headed and how can we
safeguard the right to privacy in our
communications and still benefit from
the advantages that analyzing data
offers us as a society bring
initialization of not-self the volume of
digital data worldwide doubles every two
years and there are constantly new
inventions like Google glass glasses
with a mini computer built into the
frame the glasses can measure speed
pinpoint the location of the wearer
recognize and analyze faces your sees it
as a surveillance tool disguised as a
lifestyle product hope you there's no
mention of tracking people reading their
social profile and that you immediately
get all the information on the wearer's
social activities it's made to appear
totally harmless I think this here is
quite extreme all the images show young
sporty super people using it in a
harmless way kishi you'll sees it as
part of her job to sensitize the younger
generation for a life in the digital
society she encourages her students to
realize they can influence what happens
and she also warns them to protect their
data privacy is precious she says and
needs to be safeguarded